can I just come in right away I like
your your hair color you changed a
little bit yeah I died I was died for a
movie that I just said the first time I
ever dyed my hair okay and you went with
it looks like it's am i right it's got
some got some red in there yeah does it
yeah I don't know I'm kind of colorblind
but I think it's red yeah
it looks like it's got some reddish in
it I didn't know if you you know wanted
to be a redhead or if that's something
that interests you you're attracted to
redheads if you find the whole idea
sexually exciting actually I brought a
lot of facts about redheads and one of
them is that redhead people have more
sex or something I think I read that
even in the fiction section of me the
ancient Greeks thought that redheads
turned into vampires after they died is
that true yes there are a lot of freaky
things that are said about redheads you
know a lot in the Middle Ages they
thought that a redheaded child was
conceived during menstruation
menstruation you're asking yeah I look
at you're asking us I love any time a
woman says how do you say menstruation
so okay you anyway
so not yeah you won't be it doesn't
sound like you love the idea of being a
red no I love it I'm just living it up
and just seeing the world in a whole new
way
you